there's obviously been a lot of
discussion and debate about no-fly zones
we are speaking about closing the sky
because there has been talk of a no-fly
zone both the sky near ukraine the issue
of a no-fly zone to close or not to
close there are no fly zones where one
nation or perhaps a group of nations
seeks to impose a level of air control
over a country or perhaps a piece of the
country the important thing i think to
grasp is that in doing that those
nations or that nation needs to be
prepared to enforce that no-fly zone
which means you need to be prepared to
shoot down enemy aircraft or perhaps
attack enemy surface to msl systems
we've seen them used before over the top
of iraq and elsewhere that's the
international community
trying to put in place a level of air
control
to reduce the type of violent activity
that's going on on the ground
so in ukraine there's been a lot of
debate about whether the west should put
a no-fly zone over the top of ukraine to
try and reduce some of that pressure
from russian forces on the ukrainian
population and on their armed forces the
reality is that setting up a no-fly zone
would lead to a direct confrontation
between nato and russia
there are
challenges that militarily you can do it
but those challenges mean you've got to
be prepared to engage russian and
perhaps belia russian aircraft and their
service to msl systems and therefore
that would be a significant escalation
from a western from a nato perspective
so at the moment the ukrainian air force
and to be fair their other armed
services are doing a fantastic job
keeping
some level of control in ukrainian
airspace the russians would have
expected to take
complete control of that airspace by now
and it's not happened and that's that's
down to
probably uh the russian air force are
not quite as good as they thought they
were but it's also
because of some really spirited really
brave really innovative really
courageous
resistance from the ukrainian armed
forces
if ukraine were to lose that ability to
at least deny russia control of its
airspace then russia would be able to to
roam freely across ukraine from another
point of view and that changes the tenor
of this campaign quite significantly not
only would it allow the russian air
force to target the ukrainian armed
forces and perhaps civilians but also
give the russian command and control
systems their commanders much better
information than they're getting at the
moment
so when i hear people talk about
humanitarian no-fly zone i i kind of
doubt that they know almost what what
that means the issue with no-fly zones
is you have to be prepared to enforce
them so if this humanitarian no-fly zone
was something that was was voluntary for
example then then there'd be no reason
for russia to comply with that no-fly
zone if it chose not to it's a bit like
shelling humanitarian corridors it kind
of promises a thing which perhaps it
can't deliver